teame
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
それでは今から日本で見たことのないものことをいくつか紹介したいと思っています
よろしくお願いします
ゴジラ忍者正しい英語が書いてあるシャツ
gackt が弾けない楽器汚いトイレ清潔なラーメン屋さん髪を橋ルーム
カットにしているホスト野生のピカチュウ古事記
全粒粉のパンを売っているスーパーコンビニの駐車場にある車の中で携帯をいじってい
ない人
カオス変に使われているタコスウェットパンツをはいて通学する女子大生番組に出て
くる食事をまずいと評価する芸人パーもかけた女の子の幽霊
職場でお茶を作っている男性キリスト教信者を
意外に安いなぁと思った車検の見積もり太ったアメリカ人くらい太った人踏み入れても
いいきれいな芝生東京でドリフトをしている車
つまり tokyo drift 列に無理やり割り込む人
非対称のケーキファイルが大きい ca さん
しつこくない nhk の人あそっかありがとね
やすいチーズ放送が一つしかない贈り物バラエティ番組の素朴なセット
居酒屋で乾杯せずに飲む人ありがとうもの乾いちゃった2つ以上のベンチプレスが置い
てある二ウム4秒以上に乗っている一般人
グレートデン古く感じないから ok の p
分クランプ炭素を取るジャニーズのメンバー努力不足が要因の失敗健康保険がない人
引きこもり
納豆パックにを l サイズもうしわけあるしたあっ
もうしわけあります失礼しない人あ
失礼しません少しでも日本のことをバカにしないか行く9時2分